N2O5 is a reagent that was used synthesize
explosives like TNT. Unfortunately, N2O5 decomposes
relatively quickly at or above room temperature,
so if you accidentally leave a bottle of it
out on the counter, you could be in trouble!
In this video, we'll approximate a solution
to the decomposition rate equation to figure
out whether a batch of N2O5 that you left
at room temperature can still be used. We'll
also determine under what conditions our approximation
is valid.
This video is part of the Linearity video
series.
Many complex systems are modeled or approximated
linearly because of the mathematical advantages.
Hi, my name is Ben Brubaker, and I'm a professor
in the Department of Mathematics at MIT.
Today we'll be talking about linear approximations.
In mathematical terms, this is just another
name for the tangent line to a function. But
the name suggests more. Linear approximations
can be used to simplify mathematical models
that are not analytically solvable. The approximated
model will have a solution that is only acceptable
under suitable conditions. However, it can
still illuminate the behavior of the system
within a certain acceptable range.
Before watching this video, you should know
the definition of the derivative, and how
to write the equation of a line with a given
slope that passes through a given point.
After watching this video, you should be able
to recognize the linear approximation of a
function as the tangent line to the function,
apply linear approximations to solve simple
differential equations, and explain the limitations
of linear approximations both mathematically
and graphically.
Let's begin by defining the linear approximation.
Recall that if a function is differentiable
at a point c, then when we zoom in on the
point c, the function begins to look more
and more like a line. This only works when
the function is "smooth"—it doesn't have
any kinks, corners, or discontinuities. Given
a function f(x), which is differentiable at
the point c, we define the linear approximation
to be the tangent line to the function at
c. This is a line whose slope equals f'(c).
As an example, let's look at the following
cubic equation: f(x) = one thirtieth x times
x minus 2 times x plus 5. This function is
differentiable everywhere, and in particular
is differentiable at the point x=3. Find the
equation of the tangent line to this cubic
equation at x=3 for yourself.
We've also found the equation for the tangent
line. To do this, we found the value of the
function at 3, which we found to be 4/5. And
then we computed the derivative and evaluated
it at x=3, which we found to be 7/6. We'll
write the tangent line as T sub 3 of (x) to
remind us that we are finding the tangent
to our function at the point 3. Then the equation
for this line can be written as T sub 3 of
x equals 4/5 + 7/6 times (x-3).
Let's take a look at the graphs of f(x) and
T sub 3 of x. The function f(x) is graphed
in red. The further we zoom into the graph
at x=3, the more it begins to resemble a straight
line. The slope of the line approaches the
value of the slope of the tangent line at
3, which is drawn in blue.
The tangent line certainly seems to be a good
approximation to our function when we are
close to x=3. But what about when we zoom
out? Is it still a good approximation? Let's
give a mathematical justification that the
tangent line is a good approximation. Our
function is differentiable at a point, say
x=3. This is equivalent to the statement that
when x is near 3, the slope of the secant
line is approximately equal to the slope of
the tangent line. That is, for x near 3 f(x)-f(3)
over x-3, is approximately equal to the value
of the derivative at 3.
In order to see why these statements are equivalent,
we need explain what we mean by "approximately
equal to". This means that we can make the
difference between these two sides as small
as any error bound we choose, provided that
we choose x close enough to 3.
And this is exactly the definition of differentiability
at the point 3.
To relate this to linear approximations, we
use a bit of algebra. First we multiply both
sides by (x-3), and we get f(x) -- f(3) approximately
equal to f'(3)(x-3). Adding f(3) to both sides,
we get that f(x) is approximately equal to
f(3)+f'(3)(x-3). And this right hand side
is the equation for the tangent line at 3.
So indeed the tangent line closely approximates
the function as long as x is close to 3.
Here we see the tangent line drawn in blue,
the function drawn in red. The graphs demonstrate
our mathematical proof that the tangent line
is a good approximation near x=3, but the
further we get from x=3 the worse the approximation
seems.
Now you might see that the function and tangent
line intersect at x=-9. Is the tangent line
a good approximation for the function near
x=-9?
No, it isn't. If we move a small distance
along the tangent line away from x=-9, this
does not model the behavior of the function
near x=-9. This property is extremely important
in applications—no measurement or observed
quantity is ever given exactly.
A1 The linearization of a function that is
differentiable at x=c is just another name
for the tangent line through c.
The A2 key properties of this tangent line
are that it shares the same value as the function
and the same first derivative of the function
at x=c. And A3 we've seen through both graphical
intuition and the definition of the derivative
that this linearization closely approximates
the function for points x sufficiently close
to c.
Let's see how we can apply a linear approximation
to simplify a problem. Let's suppose that
you are participating in undergraduate research
in a chemistry lab. You have been using a
.01 molar solution of N2O5. You bring it out
of the refrigerator at 9:00 Monday morning,
and promptly forget about it, leaving it on
the counter in the lab, which is 25 degrees
Celsius. When you realize you left the solution
out, 1 hour has passed. You panic.
The problem is that N205 decomposes into NO2
and O2 at room temperature. If the molarity
of the solution has changed significantly,
it might ruin your experiments. Experiments
have shown that the rate of decomposition
follows first order kinetics. This means that
the instantaneous rate of change in concentration
of N205 is proportional to the concentration
of N205. The constant of proportionality,
k, has been found experimentally to be 1.72
times ten to the negative 5 inverse seconds.
Because you are panicking, you are having
a hard time solving this differential equation.
Instead, find the _approximate_ decomposition
in the N205 solution after 1 hour using a
linear approximation at time t=0. Note that
because the reaction constant has units of
inverse seconds, the variable t must have
units of seconds.
In order to produce a linear approximation
at t=0, we need two ingredients: the concentration
at time 0, and the value of the derivative
at time 0.
The initial concentration was .01 molar. To
find the value of the derivative, we use our
differential equation, and we find that the
value of the derivative at time t=0 is just
minus k times the initial concentration at
t=0, or negative k times .01 molar. Remember
that k has units of inverse seconds.
Putting this together into the formula for
the tangent line at zero, we see that the
linear approximation, is given by T0(t)= (.01
molar) times 1 minus $kt$.
Now we are interested in approximating the
value at 1 hour, or 3600 seconds. Plugging
in the value for k, we find that to two significant
figures T0(3600)=.0094 Molar. So the molarity
is not so different. Phew!!
Now you are feeling relieved, so when you
look back at the reaction rate, you realize
that in fact, a first order reaction rate
is telling you that the concentration is some
function of time whose derivative is proportional
to itself.
The function with this property is the exponential
function! So the concentration function is
equal to some constant times e to the negative
kt.
The constant must be the initial concentration,
which is .01 Molar, so [N2O5]=(.01)e^.
Evaluating this expression at time t=3600,
we find that the exact concentration is also
.0094 Molar to two significant figures. To
be more precise, we can look at the error,
which is the absolute value of the exact solution
minus the approximate solution all divided
by the exact solution.
The error at time t=3600 seconds is .002 or
.2%.
This is really quite good. Generally speaking,
we might consider an error of less than 5%
to be acceptable.
So our linear approximation was definitely
within the acceptable range 1 hour later.
But now it's Tuesday. Today you leave the
.01 Molar N2O5 on the counter for a full 10
hours. Oops.
We know that the exact solution is an exponential
decay.
So do you think that the linear approximation
will be an over estimate, an under estimate,
or equal to the exact solution after 10 hours?
[pause]
The linear approximation of the concentration
after 10 hours at room temperature is T0(36000)=
.0038 Molar.
The exact solution of the concentration after
10 hours is .0054 Molar. Comparing these two
solutions, we see that linear approximation
is an under estimate as we would expect, with
error is .29 or 29%. So a linear approximation
is definitely not acceptable for this time
range.
But now you begin to wonder, for what times
is the linear approximation at t=0 within
5% error of the exact solution? [pause] Because
we are only interested in positive time values,
you should have found that the approximation
is acceptable for times 0 less than t less
than 16, 700 seconds, which is about 4.5 hours.
Now that you've carefully examined this problem
using linear approximation, it is probably
time to tell your graduate student adviser
that you need to order a new batch of N_2
O_5 solution.
Let's review. A1 The linear approximation
to a function at a point c is the tangent
line of a function at c. A2 This linear approximation
only accurately models the function for points
sufficiently close to c. A3 It is easy to
read off the derivative at a point from a
differential equation, and thus give a linear
approximation to the solution. In our example
with the concentration of N205, we could also
solve the differential equation exactly and
demonstrate that the approximation was acceptable
near the point of approximation t=0, but not
so for larger time intervals.
Notice that we used this simple example to
illustrate linear approximation because we
could also solve it exactly and use the exact
solution to determine the error. This is somewhat
misleading, since we often want to use linear
approximation precisely when the differential
equation that describes our physical situation
does not have an analytic solution.
So you may wonder, is there a way to estimate
the error in a linear approximation without
knowing the exact solution. The answer is
yes! However, it involves Taylor's Remainder
theorem, which finds an acceptable range in
terms of higher order derivatives, and is
beyond the scope this video.